wealth does not ruin people it exposes
who they are if someone says well $1,000
is not enough of course it's not enough
it wasn't intended to be enough any skin
color any sex Any Nation you come from
if you want corn no exceptions you have
to plant corn we've heard some news that
you are considering retiring
soon so Dave Ramsey welcome back on the
iced coffee hour I'm on here twice I
know that means your your uh popularity
didn't completely plummet it didn't so
here we are again and we've heard some
news that you are considering retiring
soon you did I did we did it's not true
it's not it's not true really who did we
get this information from well I mean
scaling scaling back I'm 63 I've been
scaling back for a long time four years
ago I quit working on on Fridays does
that count I feel like that's getting
there yeah that's a step in the right
direction we you know we moved my son uh
12 years he's been working here and
moved him the operating board moved him
him into the president's role in January
um uh what is that now 9 10 months ago
and he and I get to work together for
the first time he's always worked for
someone else here so we're having a
blast working together uh so for this
next season I'm the CEO and he's the
president and um no I'm not someday I
will retire but retirement for me will
actually be I'll still do the show as
long as I make sense if I quit making
sense and I start hurting the brand then
we'll have to take me off but um that'll
happen to or become completely
irrelevant and just an angry Boomer
but but close now maybe but anyway but
the uh uh yeah we'll do that uh and I'll
stop I'll continue to speak uh as much
as I can and those kinds of things I
enjoy those things and so that'll be my
retirement to do those things but I'll
be down here most days how much thought
do you put into Legacy in terms of
building your business passing it on and
making sure that everyone you give it to
doesn't take it for granted way too much
um I started uh 15 years ago um and
operating board we set annual goals
around uh brand transfer ownership
transfer um uh and Legacy and Leadership
transfer uh and those are all Legacy
items succession planning if you will
and so yeah we've been working very very
hard on it for 15 years and it's harder
than I thought it was going to be uh in
our case there's really three elements
the ownership issue which means I need
to raise the Ramsay kids and teach them
business Acumen over a series of decades
which we've done to be wise owners
because even if I got good leadership
team if the if the owners are dumb and
then they make the good leadership team
do dumb things the good leadership team
will leave uh and the company will go
down okay the Legacy will be blown up so
the you have to have wise owners and you
have to have a quality leadership team
bench depth they carry on the the values
in our case is different than and would
be in anybody in our space all of us um
when you are the product of the brand
You've Got a Brand transfer that's very
difficult and that the others there were
good best practices we found lots of
people that had transferred you know
generational businesses ownership wise
and Leadership wise found lots of good
data out there lots of good books and
families we could talk to that had done
it they're on Gen 4 gen five that kind
of thing and so lots of best practices
we could get but it's very hard to find
somebody's done a brand transfer like
ours uh because I'm was a stinking brand
Y and when I'm not there what's the
brand uh and so uh we started working on
what we now call these days call ramsy
personalities instead of doing a
onetoone handoff uh it turns off turns
out being the guy that follows the guys
almost impossible it's it's almost 100%
failure rate Paul Harvey Jr very seldom
can take Paul Harvey seat casionally it
works but it's it's so rare it's not
something you want to model but we did
figure out a one to many had a chance
and so that's why I didn't put the whole
thing on my daughter Rachel Cruz's
shoulders and then we have now raised up
a George camel and and a Jade warshaw
and a John deloney and a Ken Coleman and
we're in not only the money space but
the other spaces and so that and we
actually have started study we had have
these dumb accounting measurements of
whether it's working it's probably more
than you wanted to know but you I'm
curious but the uh uh when we started it
was like okay I'm producing all the
revenue off of my brand and so if I die
today you know what happens to all these
employees well they're screwed the whole
thing's going to fold up like a bad tent
you know that's where it started when I
was 48 years old and we said okay then
we need to measure nonay Revenue so if
Rachel is going and making doing a book
that's non-day revenue or if uh Ken
Coleman goes and speaks somewhere that
speaking fee is a nonay revenue right
which is kind of a yeah weird we've had
have dumb names for around here for
stuff all the time um and so uh then we
started calling it worse now it's called
the survivability index that sounds a
bit morbid it's like when we get now
it's awful it's like when we get to Once
year we do an estate planning meeting
where we talk to all the leaders and all
the owners and about what happens if
Dave dies this year and I call it the
Monty Python meeting I'm feeling much
better it's just a flesh wound you know
it's like oh my God it's horrible I'm
sitting there talking about me dying for
an hour and a half and yeah but you have
to plan it because otherwise you just uh
you ensure the failure of of the thing
you've worked so hard to build are you
treating your health differently as a
result of that of of the survivability
index of hey maybe I should go to the
gym more get more exercise heier you
know it actually takes the it takes the
weight off of me the more and you know
we had a goal of having by by the year
20 uh 2022 we wanted it to be a 50% of
the revenue was not mine um and the
great news is is that in 2023 we're at
about
78% survive if I'm not here because it's
not only that they're producing it but
it's we built the business models out in
such a way that it's not Dave dependent
to continue to run okay for instance our
high school curriculum is a520 million
business in high schools they don't care
if I'm live that that's got like a 98%
survivability right and so like I don't
know teachers are like Dave died we
can't teach it anymore because I'm not
even in the videos so hardly just a
little bit and we could chop those out
in 20 minutes so yeah that or they could
chop those out I won't be here but um
yeah that's that's kind of stuff it's
very interesting it makes you think
about your business model stuff and it
takes the pressure off of that
um and uh uh so it's just it's it's
weird to it's awkward but if you don't
talk about it you screw it up yeah I'm
curious on passing on the Legacy how are
you going to ensure that the people that
end up taking your place are going to be
able to fill those shoes because they're
massive shoes to fill and a lot of the
times like you were mentioning you need
to take it very slow and you need to
make sure that they work for it you
mentioned your son now he's in the the
role of being president of the company I
heard from somebody that he had to climb
that ladder one rung at a time it wasn't
it was not easy so how intenal about
doing that cuz a lot of people they mess
it up General generational wealth
usually only lasts like three
generations as they say well again we
studied some principles and and some of
them were that that you can't obviously
nepotism leads to the destruction of
Legacy so um meaning putting someone
that's incompetent into a role because
they happen to hit the DNA Lottery um
you know happen to be in your bloodline
that's just Dumber in a rock and the
other thing is we want to put people in
roles that they fit in David Green told
me at Hobby Lobby he said the job is to
climb a tree get a squirrel not a dog
you know and so you know my children are
the Bible says train up a child in the
way he's is bent is the old old King
James and train up a child the way he's
bent the way he is made and and when
he's old he'll not depart from it and so
we did not put Rachel who's very good on
camera very good on stage in incredible
on social media uh horrible on details
we did not put her in charge of
accounting the whole place would be gone
it would have burned down okay and and
so you know put her put her where she's
a dancing poodle I mean everybody I've
got three kids everybody's got kid that
comes out with a cigar and a bottle of
champagne Rachel's that kid she's a
party looking for a place to happen
she's perfect for this and she's
brilliant she's world class at it but to
make her the
CEO the the people would just leave not
because they don't like her because
everybody likes her but because they
would have no idea what we're doing cuz
there would we would not we would make
it up every morning and you it's not and
my son Daniel's quite the opposite he
does not want to be on camera uh and on
stage uh but he's very entrepreneurial
and you know loves products and digital
products and projects and design you
know organizational design and all this
stuff and so you know put put them where
their put them where their strengths are
and you got a good shot at doing that
but you can't ensure the only thing we
can do is to test and gradually do it so
you know like for instance when we went
to uh one of the moves we made was two
years ago we went from the Dave Ramsey
Show to the Ramsey Show and we thought
it was a huge
deal and the weird thing is we did not
announce it we didn't even tell our 680
radio stations two radio stations called
us and loved it none of the rest of them
noticed our listenership in the comments
was they just changed the name well
that's cool well they're doing that
succession thing they talk about okay
that's
cool and then it was over for us it was
this big emotional thing and it was oh W
are we making a chance are we going from
Coke to original Coke and nobody cared
but us so you think it was better not to
announce it just do oh it turns out it
was genius not to announce it okay uh in
that case we just did it and then for
the first eight months or so if I wasn't
on the air the numbers were down I had a
co-host like I do now on the Ramsey show
but if or if I wasn't there at all it
was two of them doing it the numbers
were down now the numbers are up when
I'm not there you're kidding serious so
people don't want to see you anymore so
distressing thisy not to be important
and your plan works it
sucks how how much does that hurt your
ego it hurt F but now it's like but it
was my plan I did it on purpose and so I
you got this on one hand it's like it
worked we're successful and on the other
hand it's like they don't like me it's
great it's it's it's a weird set of
emotions to how do you set your owns
plan to be less important and how do you
set your feelings aside on something
like that and don't take it personally
and and view it objectively I have work
you know the way you do it I
intellectually make the decision of it's
what I was trying to do so I really
shouldn't gripe about it I was really
trying to make it where this place
survives without me hello and that it
you know how how do you ensure that
generationally it doesn't crash when
Dave's gone you know and well you put it
on before you're gone and you make it
work before you're gone and then it did
and Dad blame it it did and so you know
it's the little boy Dave that's six
years old and wants to be important that
lives inside of me and still lives
inside of everyone uh is he's got his
little feelings hurt but the the man
Dave who's thinking about Legacy and
generational change and my grandkids and
my great-grandkids and the number of
lives that'll be touched because we did
this right after I'm gone uh that guy's
real proud but before we get into that
I'm sure you guys have been hearing this
absolutely everywhere and for good
reason that AI might now be the most
important new technology out there it's
storming every industry and literally
billions of dollars are being invested
so buckle up the problem though is that
AI needs a lot of speed and processing
power so how are you able to keep up
without your cost spiraling out of
control that's why it's time to upgrade
to the next generation of the cloud
Oracle Cloud infrastructure or oci oci
is a single platform for your
infrastructure database application
development and AI needs oci has four to
eight times the bandwidth of other
clouds they offer one consistent price
instead of variable Regional pricing and
of course Nobody Does it Better Than
Oracle so now you could train your AI
models at twice the speed and at less
than half the price of other clouds if
you want to do more and spend less like
uber 8x8 and datab Bricks Mosaic take a
free test drive of oci at oracle.com IED
once again it's oracle.com sisted it is
completely free for a test drive at
oracle.com
iced thank you so much Oracle and back
to the podcast and also on your kids
business aside how do you make sure that
they don't go and become insane and do
all these things that a lot of wealthy
kids don't end up doing well like like
you're a savant in business but you're
also a savant in The Family Arena as
well which I no I'm serious I like it's
not spend more time with the ramies but
I'm a lot of people we talk to like the
wealthy people man they're kids they go
off and they every wants to become an
artist which there's nothing wrong with
that but usually it's just a decoy
because they can't find their actual
ambition or passion seem but how do you
Foster that well I mean there's a couple
things we learned thank god um after
going broke and our kids were growing up
as we were growing wealth they they
weren't born into wealth they were just
it was just there by the time they were
grown one thing is my friend Andy Anders
says don't raise kids to be great kids
raise kids to be great
adults and so teach them critical
thinking skills if I'm making you do
something in you're 8 years old and
we're having a big argument about it all
the time I haven't really explained to
you why I'm making you do it like you
need to brush your teeth I want to brush
my teeth I come up here I trush my teeth
your toothbrush is dry now you lied and
you didn't brush your teeth now we got
two problems right and this has happened
at the Remy house I can just tell it
sounds like it has who's not brushing
your teeth so what what's the big deal
about brushing your teeth cuz you know I
want adult children that have
teeth that's why you do it right I mean
how do you want them to turn out out I
want them to have you know you know
daughters are going on a date my son's
going on a date in high school it's like
uh I kind of think that's person's
scummy that you why would you do that um
because you might end up with them and
then your life's going to suck you know
if you you know plug your life into
scummy over here and so we teach them I
used to say we've got great in-laws I
mean my daughter-in-law my two
sons-in-law are fabulous they're world
class and I used to say man I hit the
in-law Lottery before Allison came along
married Daniel and now it's I hit the
in-law Lottery right but I quit saying
that CU it wasn't it wasn't accidental I
taught them how to pick and they picked
well what qualities do you teach them to
look for in a person that they pick like
that I think it's kind of Common Sense
everyone would answer that probably the
same somewhat the same anyway uh
Integrity work ethic uh a desire to
serve others to not be
abusive uh you know toxic human beings
are going to exude toxicity right um and
in our case we're a family of faith and
so we're you know are you walking with
God and so because that's going to lead
you to these other character qualities
as well is how it's happened with me in
my life and happened with my kids so um
you know but it wasn't like some kind of
legalistic things like you must marry a
Baptist no it's wasn't that it was more
like look these are values that we have
and here's a place you're going to find
them is with people that think that way
even then obviously they're uh they come
from uh different things and so you know
every one of my kids has 100% of them
have had fights with their spouses 100%
of them uh spend time learning how to be
married and often times see a marriage
counselor or therapist that's there's
nothing wrong with that that's just
training and that but we taught them to
do that too so we did it Shar and I did
it so why not and so um read books on
how to do marriage if you want to be
married well and so all that stuff so
all of that's the second answer your
question Jack is how do you raise kids
in a wealthy family the wealth doesn't
ruin them wealth does not ruin people it
exposes who they
are wealth is ambivalent it's it's uh
amoral it doesn't and in the case of you
or me too it it it just magnifies Who I
Am the good parts of me the bad parts of
me get really big the more money I have
so if someone has a problem with their
temper and they get wealth and and
they're rageaholic and nobody wants to
be around them they're absolute bully
out of control you know or if
they're kind and very giving and they
get wealth they become known for their
generosity
worldwide for their generosity it's like
it's they're like a picture of
generosity but they were already a
person who was generous or they had
already developed the generosity muscle
before they got wealth they didn't
suddenly become generous because they
got wealth it just exposed who they are
and the same's true with kids so if you
raise kids that are lazy that don't work
hard that don't tell the truth that lie
that are intitled because they grew up
and you know they were born on third
base thought they hit a triple right
then you give the money well they're
going to be useless but they were
already useless the wealth just showed
us that how do you test Financial
compatibility with a partner and is that
something you could change about a
person you can present someone the
option to change and then they decide to
change but you can't change other people
on anything uh all I can do is present
an idea and then you decide if you're
going to pick it up or not you know the
way we've taught it on the air for years
is the the data tells us that if you can
agree on four things prior to marriage
the probability of you still being
married 40 years later is very high if
you can agree on your money because when
you agree on how money is going to be
handled you're agreeing on your fears
you're agreeing on on your anxieties
you're agreeing on your dreams you're
agreeing on your values because money
flows to those things so if you can
agree on your money it's very important
if you can agree on kids how many we
going to have how we going to raise them
are we going to be are we going to
manage the children or are they going to
manage us you know that kind of stuff um
in-laws crazy as in the family cuz there
every family's got crazy in it and if
you don't think there's crazy in your
family it means it's you and so um you
know so anyway you got to deal you got
how we going to have boundaries in other
words and then the fourth is be in
agreement on religion if we're going to
be uh atheists then let's both you know
let's be in agreement about that if
we're going to be Christian you know
it's been there very few cross religion
marriages end up making it long term
because again it's a value system thing
sure it's what your it's how you live
your life how you your decision-making
Paradigm comes out of your value system
and so that ends up there so the data
says if you agree on those four things
so once I know that and by the way
number one cause of divorce is money
problems and money fights if I know that
and I'm dating then it becomes very
important if we're going to get married
that we're compatible or that we at
least agree prior to marriage okay now
you could start out and be going you
know in the uh like in the case of uh
Rachel tells the story of Winston taking
her out on their first date and they
used a credit card to buy the pizza you
know and so you don't throw Winston away
because he used used a credit card in
the Ramsey family right did she want to
yeah uh he he bought the pizza it's his
problem right and so um you know that
that's what's necessary but the um
someone explained to Winston later on
that's Dave Ramsey's daughter used a
credit card you're you know made
fun of him and then it was became a
funny thing later but uh but you know
that's not an indication that we're not
compatible on one date it just said okay
there's a thing there that the ramies
don't use credit cards so we got to talk
about this ahead of time and we got to
decide how we're going to do that um so
typically you don't have to be you don't
want to be the same like my wife is a
saver and I'm a spender my wife is a
scarcity person and I'm an abundance
person so risk I I'm more much heavier
risk tolerance than she has um and and
you need that balance that
counterbalance um Larry brette used to
say if two people just like get married
one of you is unnecessary so you don't
want to be just alike but you do need to
have a value system like if if you
detest for instance in our case detest
being in debt you can't stand it and you
marry somebody who just is going to
borrow all the time you're going to have
a problem hello I mean that no kidding
and so or you like to have a plan and
know where things are going and the
other person refuses to participate in
that you're going to have a problem but
there's other stuff going on there
beneath the surface anyway it's more
than more than just the money the money
is just revealing it I'm curious on
finances and what keeps people poor how
often can you chalk it up to systemic
issues like credit and you know payday
loans and different predatory loans
taking advantage of people versus their
own responsibility financial literacy
versus just you know not being subjected
to financial literacy as they're growing
up yeah could be the economy too or
could be the economy yeah that
upbringing I think it's everything it's
um it's all of those things and so where
do we chalk it up to the ones that those
of us like me that make it out I mean I
didn't grow up with any money so what's
the difference in me and my next door
neighbor we had the same skin color we
had the same accent we had the same uh
elementary school and then why am I
sitting here and he's not uh in terms of
net worth okay what's different um so
the systemic things are there and and
they do take pockets of people and and
there are industries that as you said
you know from a Biblical perspective we
would say he oppressed the poor it's one
of the most horrible things you can do
to take advantage of a widow and orphan
and the poor you know it's just it's
antihuman it's evil and so these
businesses that feed on the poor are
just they have at their very
core a detestable immorality and so they
are oppressors of the poor Lord help
them you know it's not going to go well
for them so you don't want to be a
person that picks on the poor uh uh you
instead want to be someone that lifts
them up or helps someone not be poor but
Mike Todd said I've been rich and I've
been broke but I've never been poor poor
is a state of
mind and so it's um oh people like us
you know we can't get ahead Eeyore is my
spirit animal oh it's bad thank God it's
Friday oh God it's Monday the little man
can't get ahead we're stuck I sure hope
the president fixes my life it's a
victim mentality or an entitlement ality
that causes you to not take action and
put corn in the ground and then you're
shocked there is no corn crop you have
to plant something if you want something
to grow there is no exceptions to that
rich poor any skin color any sex Any
Nation you come from if you want corn no
exceptions you have to plant corn if you
want something to come into your life
you have to cause that cause and effect
wise what to happen it's like in the
investing world that we all talk about
all the time the interesting statistic
is 96% one study showed of whether
someone is able to build wealth in their
retirement plan has to do with whether
they actually put money in
it it's not the rate of return it's not
the 12 B1 fees it's not no load versus
load it's not bogal passive investing
versus buying mutual funds from a broker
it's none of that it's did you actually
take action and put money into the
freaking account you know and did you
plant the corn you know did you plant
the corn don't and then you stand back
and go well the corn reason the corn
didn't grow is I didn't have right fer
fertilizer no you put no corn in the
ground you know and so there is
definitely uh Prejudice out there
because there's ignorant people out
there there's definitely racism out
there there's ignorant people out there
there's definitely sexism out there
because there's ignorant people out
there and those are systemic things that
affect your personal economy it affects
the opportunities that are in front of
you it affects all of those things but
there are yet and yet in every one of
those cases we can find many many
examples who people that overcame those
things I mean I'm from the south and I
have a Southern accent which by
definition for some people in the north
because they're stereotypically idiots
uh they immediately assume that because
I have a Southern accent that my IQ is
lower than theirs that's you know but is
that a barrier for my broadcast yes I
had to go take voice and and get some of
I got rid of about 80% of my country
fried redneck accent I kept a little for
flavor but um but the uh but you know
but I I had to work on that because
people in Boston are like I don't even
know what he's saying and it can't be
right because it sounds like he's
broadcasting from a double wide you know
and so but that's a barrier that's a
systemic barrier and so you've got to
deal with okay that's a blocker uh how
much has they got to get over it and how
much have I got to get over it and how
much is somebody saying you're never
going to make it because of that and I
go make it anyway but before we get into
that running a business can be
incredibly rewarding but obviously you
still need the basics and fundamentals
down if you want your business to run
smoothly this includes items like a CPA
bookkeeper separate Payroll Solutions
and so on plus and I say this from
experience the more your business scales
the more complicated it gets and the
more you need to pay attention to this
well with today's sponsor Collective you
can make sure that you don't only just
do that but you also save thousands of
dollars and countless hours in the
meantime Collective is the solution for
contractors Freelancers and
self-employed entrepreneurs that allows
them to focus on their passion not the
paperwork Collective handles compliance
taxes bookkeeping accounting and even
payroll and the best part is that it's
only a fraction of the cost of a CPA if
your business of one makes over $80,000
a year you will find the most value from
their services so join the thousands of
entrepreneurs who have saved an average
of $10,000 a year on their taxes with
their structure right now Collective is
offering one month free and no
onboarding fee at collective.com
that by the way is $550 worth of value
when you go to Collective
/ic and let them know that I sent you
once again guys it's 1 month for free
with no onboarding fee so try it out and
if you don't like it that's totally fine
it's completely free at collective.com
thank you so much Collective and back to
the episode now you're talking about a
victim mindset do you think that's more
prevalent today with social media or do
you feel like it was more prevalent 20
30 years ago no it's always been there
social media just gave my voice sure but
do you feel like other people hearing
victim mentalities online they could
more relate to it
and they get and it might again they
just it's a it's a campfire they can get
around it's just a very large campfire
sure and that tribe is the victim tribe
and you you know you found your people
and you know it's a bunch of trolls and
um you know I'm going to whine and gripe
and blame everybody else and it's this
and that it's this and that because I
refuse to go plant corn you know yes I'm
I'm I'm validating and saying I hear you
I see you that those things are real
they've happened to me you know you
here's a weird one okay the number of
people that are successful on network
television that have no hair that are
male think about it I None yeah okay so
I'm I'm a victim of baldis you have some
hair but hey I refuse to go get a tpay
or a hair implant so I'm probably not
going to be on the cool Channel with the
HD beautiful people I'm on there as a
guest cuz I'm a dancing animal but but
other than that yeah when you were
losing your hair did you ever have the
desire to get a transplant to toe or
like try to keep it at all or you just
embracing it for a while I didn't think
anything about it and then it was gone
and I thought well now it's on a book
cover and so if I go get a if I go get
hair then they're going to go wait
minute you used to not have hair and
that's weird and you know so I'm you
know it's like glasses I could I you
know I wear contacts you know when I'm
playing golf or scuba or doing anything
Sports wise you know we do a lot of
water skiting I wear contacts I wear
contacts almost all weekend uh or when I
get home but I you know but 25 million
books with these glasses so it was like
Dave what' you do what you do what's
different what's different took the
glasses off but yeah so I still wear the
glasses that's we did a podcast recently
with Ty Lopez who said that he keeps his
glasses on even though he got lasic and
he takes the frames out so that when
he's on camera you don't see the
reflection of the glasses oh wow because
his brand is so recognizable with him
wearing glasses yeah I couldn't get
lasic so I didn't do that but I actually
have some blanks they're glasses but
they don't have any prescription in them
in case I've got the in in case I got
contacts in I can reach in my backpack
and throw them on and jump on stage and
not think anything about it oh my gosh
yeah it's crazy but I mean it it's just
no I never thought anything about it I
don't it's not I I I've never been uh
I'm not one of the Blessed people that
um has been able to open doors using my
appearance so it's never been an
issue so going back to money um do
people just know what's what they should
be doing and what's best for them and
why don't they do that if people know
they should just contribute what do you
think the reason is that they just
decide I'm not going to do this I know I
should be saving but I'll do that
tomorrow I'm not positive but I think it
has something to do with
hope
um I like
pizza but I know if I eat like the whole
thing that I'm going to continue to be
an Loompa I'm going to continue to be
overweight right and so so why is it
that you know um a I don't want to pay
the price to get the different result or
B I don't believe that if I do it it's
really going to work that's that's
called hopelessness lack of Hope and so
I don't believe if I save money I can
really be a millionaire and even if I
became a millionaire million is not
enough and so I'm not going to do any of
it just cuz I don't believe it's going
to end up with a better life for having
saved that money so I'll just spend the
money and have a great great weekend and
then Monday I'll be broke and have
anxiety about my money again because I
don't believe it's going to work but so
half of our job on Ramsey
show has been over these decades is to
inject hope cause people with math or
cause people with a discussion or cause
people with uh humor or a story or
someone else's debt free scream to
believe they can do it it's one of the
reasons we have eight bazillion debt
free screams on YouTube
because I'll guarantee you there's
somebody like whoever's watching this
like you there's somebody like you on
there CU I mean there's 8 million I
don't know how many hundreds and
thousands now of those debt free screams
on there so there's a single mom that's
52 years old that cuts hair and she's on
there and so if you're a single mom and
you cut hair she's on there she did it
it makes that's social proof you know
makes her believe she can do it that's
hope and and sometimes you hear me just
do it with math and you go you know $100
a month save for 25 to 65 is you know
going to be somewhere around a million
million and a half depending on what
your rate of return is but 10 to 12%
somewhere in there that's what you're
going to have $100 a month so shut up go
do it they go I didn't know I could do
that that sounds attainable sounds like
I could do it well you can do it you can
do it and or I got $100,000 in student
loan debt and I don't know how I'm going
to get out okay well what do you make
$100,000 okay well what about
$25,000 for 4 years you could be out in
four years or what about
$33,000 for 3 years
could you do that or could you work a
little extra and be done in two years
and live on almost absolutely nothing
and your friends think you're
crazy yeah I never thought of that but
sixth grade math I did a long division
from the sixth grade no Insight
here it's just hope that is so I've
never thought about it being hope but it
makes sense it makes because the math
really is so easy it is sorry yeah
you're fine you're good that is that is
a that is a unique take I did not expect
you to say that but I I actually really
like that you would never go to the
trouble to go out in the sun with a hoe
and dig up the ground and put the corn
in the ground and then make sure it was
watered and then make sure the weeds are
killed and then keep the animals off of
it so that the corn would grow you would
never go to that trouble if you didn't
believe corn was going to grow that's
hope why would you plant corn and go to
all that trouble it's easier to sit at
home watch Tiger King on Netflix I mean
why would you go to all that trouble
right you know why would I put myself
out there why would I risk embarrassment
why would I um sweat versus not sweat
why would I be tired versus not be tired
unless I believed it was going to work I
think that can be applied to just taking
action in any direction in life as well
same as like you know maybe being a
YouTuber a lot of people they they want
to be a YouTuber but they feel like even
if they put in all the time and effort
to make all these videos and put
themselves out there they're not going
to be successful at it so why bother in
the first place well 100% of them that
don't try won't get there true yeah I
mean we've done detailed research right
true true so I mean you may just
embarrass yourself you probably will
actually I do certain I've made a good
living embarrassing myself but but yeah
it's uh sometimes I look back and I go
what in the world are you doing there's
one running around YouTube right now
somebody posted on there uh of me at on
a Christian bad it was like a Saturday
Night Live skit bad Christian TV and I'm
on there and and it was like I was 31
years old it was 31 years ago and I'm
just like yeah and you can get out of
dead and here's what this says and I'm
saying it's very country fried and I got
this little combover going cuz I hadn't
lost my hair yet to your point and all
this stuff but and but the comments on
YouTube are like he still he's saying it
better now he actually looks better now
but he's saying exactly the same thing
it's like yeah that's true it's still
the same thing but it's somebody dug
that up and oh it's it's it's a clown
show it's awful look at what's something
that you think you could be doing better
about your own finances I could spend
more time um more carefully
and aggressive aggressively is not the
word more
intentionally uh investing I'm a little
bit halfhazard I just buy a mutual fund
put it on a pilot forget I own it I you
know I'm looking at real estate and I'm
checking I check my llc's I check the
you know the rent rolls I check that
stuff I you know I don't like vacancies
you know I don't like tenis not paying I
want I'm going to know that stuff but I
haven't sat and went okay I could move
that and I could do that and can
manipulate that I probably could do a
lot better at that I I I tend to set it
and let it go too much
and that's not a that's not a suggestion
people it's saying saying a weakness
it's something I could do better at the
good news is I'm a little bit add a lot
and so if I screwed with it as much as
my brain told me to I would have undone
half the good stuff that happened by
leaving it alone so it's worked to my
advantage to set it and forget it a
little bit but I'm also missing some
things that I could I could tighten up
some stuff and do a little better but
it's not it's it's okay we're okay I
have a question on one of the I would
say one of the most common critic
criticisms that people have of you which
is kind of like this undertone of a
slight refusal to change which would be
obviously the debt thing which I
actually don't NE I I agree with that I
like your debt takes but also unlike the
Thousand emergency fund and other
aspects that you've kind of like held
true for I don't know 30 probably yeah
30 plus years at this point do you think
that overall that's worked in your
advantage do you think that maybe you've
cemented yourself in with these
positions a little bit too hard or are
you content and satisfied with it what
do you think about changing in on these
like core beliefs could that be
productive well there's two buckets that
those things fall into um and uh uh not
to be smart alic or anything but if we
thought that we needed to change them we
would have changed them they're not said
it and forget it there stuff we we see
the criticism we go well you just didn't
understand this or didn't understand
that but so so uh for me your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and when you don't have any debt
you have you've eliminated the vast
majority of risk and you've freed up
this cash flow to Bill wealth and um and
if then in an asset the same thing
occurs for instance a piece of real
estate if it's paid for the cash flow is
going zoom zoom it cash flows more than
if you have debt on it duh you don't
have a payment so you've increased your
cash flow you've lowered your risk
you've increased your cash flow you've
lowered your risk stay out of debt and
so mathematically and I've proven in my
personal life and tens of millions of
people have proven it
becoming baby steps millionaires that
you know going on that path so that's a
principle for me that falls kind of like
it's the law of gravity MH you can
either like it or not like it but it's
still a law it's still that's just so no
I'm not changing that one that one's not
that one's not mine that's something I
observed you know wealthy people doing I
observed it in scripture I've observed
it where in places where I felt like I
had a body of truth that this is a it's
as Dependable as a law of gravity for
for in another one is you know I'm not
ever going to tell you to to that
budgeting doesn't work because 100% of
businesses that are successful budget
each p&l within the business I've got 14
pnls inside Ramsey we budget those we
not because I'm Dave Ramsey but because
that's how you run a freaking business
you know you don't you don't
accidentally become successful it's it's
a you know we plan it and then we
measure against the plan we plan it and
we measure against the plan and uh Zig
Ziggler said if you aim at nothing
you'll hit it every time and so you plan
it and you measure against the plan same
thing as the succession we were talking
about earlier all of that you plan it
you measure against the plan you got to
have a survivability index God help us
you know you plan it you measure against
the plan and so you know someone there's
been books or people come out and say
you don't need to do a budget budgets
are stupid budget no they're not it's
the only possible way to win no one
accidentally wins at anything so that's
a principle like the law of gravity the
Thousand thing is different um that's
not a principle that's just a baby step
and we could change it if we wanted to
but if someone says well $1,000 is not
enough of course it's not enough it
wasn't enough when I put it in place 20
years ago it wasn't intended to be
enough we're not saying a $1,000
emergency fund is adquate it's more
adequate than zero and it's and it it
makes you a little bit scared because
you only have a th so you get your
button gear and get out of Deb and baby
step two using the Deb snowball then I
did my job it's not supposed to be
adequate and so you know it needs to be
inflation adjusted well inflation
adjusted means that it was adequate no
it's not adequate 3 to 6 months of
expenses is a proper emergency fund
that's baby step three after you're out
of debt that's adequate and that
automatically adjusts because it the way
the formula is it's it inflation adjusts
or whatever 3 to six months of expenses
are different today than they were when
I started teaching it 25 years ago but
the formula inflation inflation adjust
right the $1,000 was never meant to be
adequate it's meant to be inadequate uh
to keep get you you know get you off the
couch and get you go get out of debt
people that follow The Total Money
Makeover baby steps for financial piece
they're out of debt not counting their
house on average 18 24 months that's
your risk window for living off $1,000
it's not like I'm saying for the rest of
your life you should only have $1,000 of
course I didn't say that so that would
of course I should be criticized if I
said that and yes I should change that
if I said that but I didn't say that
that's not how this works the way it
works is three we're trying to get to
three to six months of expenses that
does inflation adjust you know I'm still
putting all the rest of the baby steps
do automatically adjust by the way the
formulas are set 15% of your income
going into retirement five doesn't have
a formula put money for your kids
college was very vague because we don't
know what how old your kid is or how
many kids you got or how wealthy you are
or whatever so you got but you need to
be doing something for educating your
kiddos so they don't live in your
basement and so all this stuff and and
you know uh so everything all this stuff
moves 25% of your income going to going
to a thing it's 25% of your income why
does that happen going to going to a
15-year fixed rate mortgage for your
personal residence why that
automatically adjusts with interest
rates it automatically adjusts with
house prices um so it doesn't need to be
changed if you put more than that in
you're still going to have sque squeezed
your disposable income you still don't
have the margin to invest the margin to
be generous you don't have the margin to
buy a couch so you put the stupid thing
on 90 days same as cash and then you
wonder why your butt's in debt because
you didn't keep margin in your budget
that's why these are basic things but
they're all formula based except the
$1,000 and I never intended it to be
adequate and I guess it makes sense when
you look at just baby steps it is a baby
step uh I like what you said about your
principles the ones that have never
changed it's not actually based off of
what you believe to be true but it's on
objective reality and you kind of just
see yourself as a mouthpiece for that
reality that's best practices I mean you
I went when I went broke and went and
talked to Old rich people and they all
told me the same thing live on less than
you make get on a budget stay out of
debt
and I wasn't doing any of that that's
why I went broke I was deeply in debt
didn't have a plan I thought I could out
earn my stupidity how did you get that
hope though after that I was hopeless so
I was I was at the bottom I was bankrupt
everything was gone you know and so man
I got hungry kids and a wife that wants
to leave but she doesn't have a car
and you know but uh yeah so I'm like I
got to you know the stuff I was told
apparently didn't work cuz I did it
perfectly I mean I I believed The
Leverage thing and went all in baby and
you know it hit me in the back of the
head and it wasn't cuz I was dumb I was
anything but dumb I was really good at
it how did you keep your marriage
together during that time the truth is
probably too much information probably
too much information but anyway the the
um um we used to laugh and say we held
on to each other just to get a better
grip you know it's like we fought a lot
uh it was really brutal but the uh uh
cuz she was really scared she was
terrified and my self-esteem was
destroyed because I got my uh
confidence Out of My Success and when my
success was gone I didn't I wasn't there
anymore I was just a shell um I was an
arrogant little jerk and so I had to
rebuild we were not just broke we were
broken and so um that's why I can still
hear it when people call that are in I
can hear it in their voice even all
these years later I can it still hits me
and my stomach gets up in my throat but
the um we had two little babies a and
there really weren't any good options I
mean leaving wasn't going to fix it uh
although we fought like crazy but um so
we just said um do the next thing do the
next thing get up go to work get some
money pay the light bill get the lights
turned back on get up go to work get the
water turned back on get up go to work
and change the diaper and feed the kid
and take the kid to school and put some
gas in the car and we really were just
almost zombified you know literally
living um dayto day emotionally and we
did that until we started making money
again and I I got back into six figures
which in those days was substantial
money and um uh we went about three
years and then everything kind of we got
we weren't rich but I mean we were not
desperate anymore broke we were paying
our bills and we had money and we could
go to the grocery store and not freak
out we had a budget and we were out of
debt and all this stuff we almost out of
debt and once all that happened then all
of those stored up feelings that we had
stuffed down just to get the day-to-day
done rose up and that's when we almost
divorced was 3 years later really cuz
we'd stuffed it down you know and then
it just blew up it boiled and blew up
and we ended up sitting with the
marriage counselor for like 3 years
after that and um that lady to this day
is one of our best friends she saved Our
Lives she saved our marriage so I'm
curious how does your wife get over not
blaming you for that situation and maybe
not holding on to any resentment and how
did you get back your self-esteem do you
think think that was just because you
started making more money and then that
came back or do you think you worked on
something differently within yourself
part of it was a spiritual walk um a
psychological emotional walk and that I
realize I put my faith in the wrong
things you know if if you put your faith
in stuff or in your net worth then it's
always going to let you down that's a
hollow thing it's a good thing to do to
go do those things but putting your
faith in that and or or drawing your
self-esteem from that you know it's um
it's gone and what determines whether I
like me what determines whether I'm a
good person or not is not based on my
net worth or based on my cash flow or
based on any of those things those
aren't those can be results of being a
good person and doing the right
disciplined things that we were talking
about earlier but uh but they're results
they're not they're not causal and so uh
just becoming a person of character I
want to become a good dad I want to
become a good husband I want to become
opening a business a good leader I want
to I want to learn how to I want to be
somebody that when I look back and I'm
80 years old look back and go that that
was a pretty good ride you know not look
back and go man I wish I hadn't done
that I wish I hadn't done that I wish
there's a lot of stuff I've done that
dumb but I don't want to do things of
character that character problems that
regret so that changing that and then
with her um you know her Terror came
from her bless her heart she thought she
had married sir Galahad and it turns out
it was goober you know I mean it was
like the guy that she counted on let her
down and so she had to also say oh I'm
not I can't place my faith in him and
then over time how did she have
confidence in me well it's track record
I mean it's like uh if somebody was an
alcoholic and I've got a good friend
alcoholic he's been he got his 20-year
coin the other day not hadn't touched
alcohol in 20 years and uh his wife
really trusts him now but 20 days after
he went to AA she didn't trust him yet
but he's got a good you know he's been a
he's not been an alcoholic for a long
long time well he would say he's still
an alcoholic but you know what I'm
saying he's not drinking right uh for a
long long time and so uh the further we
get from this and the more wealth we get
the more she realizes I'm not the guy
the same person that made those bad
decisions I'm not this crazy risk-taking
fool that believes that you know that
the rules don't apply to me in terms of
the principle of debt free that kind of
stuff so fact that we've lived these
principles and we still do at the Ramsey
and one of those principles is I don't
do things um uh we said in the old days
we don't buy anything over $300 without
talking about it today we would say we
don't do things of size without talking
about them we don't do give large
charitable gifts um without us agreeing
that that's a good thing to give that to
a good person to help a good situation
that we want to put money into I don't
just say hey honey look what I did I
don't go buy a boat I don't go buy a car
to this day I still don't I call her and
go hey this is what I'm looking at I'm
thinking about this I just found this I
think I might get it is it okay with you
yeah that's fine so I'm curious do you
guys have any Financial disagreements
today or is mostly anything almost
everything's good at this point like if
you say I want to buy this boat would
she ever say no I don't like that boat's
too big too much money I don't know if a
disagreement is like no you should not
do that yes I want to do that is type of
disagreement but what we do is she says
I think I want to go to um she's did a
trip with a bunch of girls went to a
dude ranch a bunch of her friends all
right she said I don't think I want to
do that I said okay how you doing that
I'm doing this and this and this and I
said um I think you ought to do it but
you probably ought to do it this way the
travel arrangements and the other stuff
and she went I thought of that yeah okay
so that if that's a disagreement then
you know we take each other's input and
so um you know uh uh but even on little
stuff we do that and so that's just
communication and a relationship is what
it amounts to but I did all kinds of
stuff that Sharon didn't even know I did
not because I was hiding it from from
her I just didn't need her permission
before and I mean we've owned real
estate to this day we'll go out to eat
somewhere and I'll go hey you know 40
years ago we owned that house right
there for about two days I flipped it
and she's like you're kidding no she
goes a friend of mine lived in that
house and I went like 10 years after I
flipped it right but but she's like but
she's I bought houses the woman had
never seen you know that's weird if you
think about it but nowadays we would
never do that we get ready to buy a
commercial property or we'll get in the
car and we'll go drive on Sunday
afternoon I go WN and I are looking at
doing this deal over here and here's the
numbers on it she yeah okay but um most
of the time that's what it sounds like
but very very few things but again we've
got 30 years of doing it right and doing
it with lots of communication and lots
of agreement um we're building our third
house together and that one will test
you yeah sure cuz you argue about stuff
all the time I mean we were picking out
cabinet hardware for God's sakes last
night and I'm like I don't like that she
goes my kitchen I went good point get it
if you want it so she gets the kitchen
what do you get I'm guessing the garage
the basement I mean there's all kinds of
stuff I get believe me I get I get
plenty but it's you know and I'm like
and I didn't hate it I just didn't like
it you know and it's like I'm not a
decorator screw it whatever I'm curious
how do you change where you draw your
self-esteem from where you place your
values from all of these like external
things like status wealth respect from
other people and stuff like that where
you were beforehand through that
transition of like I guess more
internally facing values like do you
respect yourself are you a good man are
you a good husband are you a good father
to to your kids how do you like make
that your primary thing I imagine it
takes a lot of time it it it is not an
instantaneous process it's a it's a
decision it's a series of decisions uh I
guess um I feel like it's a biological
thing to to command respect from other
people to want to elevate your status oh
I think we all do that I mean I want to
be liked I don't like all the dayve
Ramsey hate that's out there I don't
love that it hurts my feelings I'm human
being you know it doesn't but but the
difference is do I draw my self-worth
from the comments on YouTube oh God help
us that's a good point that would be bad
right be very bad yeah that would be
horrible it'll change by the day yeah
the video it's like I can't decide if I
like me or
not oh God I mean that's that's a funny
way of saying the whole thing in a way
is um am I taking a
poll uh and that's what affirmation is
from anybody the thing I had to figure
out was if I'm going to listen to
someone uh and let them have influence
over my emotions and over my decisions
it needs to be people really close to me
that love me not people in the distant
world of the internet throwing grenades
they don't get a vote um and so they
think they've got a vote which is
humorous to me but they don't have a
vote I don't even read the stuff I mean
George kemel he follows all this stuff
he' come in and tell me stuff they're
saying I'm like really that's fun let's
do a little bit on that and uh but I
don't I don't sit cuz I don't take a
poll I'm not I didn't say what I said or
do what I did to make that person over
there happy I did it to help somebody
else and if it didn't work it didn't
work anyway so how do you change that
it's a decision where you place it in my
case I cheated Jack because everything I
believed in was taken from me when I
went through bankruptcy my
status uh my
confidence uh my belief in uh the
financial principles that I had learned
getting a finance degree which are all
leverage-based
uh my you know my wife's uh um
admiration was gone my uh I I don't know
there was no you had to find something I
didn't have a choice in my case so I
cheated but if you got a choice I guess
you'd have to just choose and say you
know what this feels shallow I feel like
a reality star instead of a human and so
this feels like a shallow way to look at
life and I'm not I'm going to just
choose not to do that anymore and
sometimes we see people in the public
eye do that to their credit they they
decide
okay they got into it from a very
shallow appearance-based perspective or
whatever else and then later on we find
out you know they really there's a lot
of character in there and they just they
made some transitions later on but it's
it's a series of choices it might be
growing up a little bit that might be
part of it we're talking about changing
for the better for your own personal
finances and you said it's hope and I
feel like it's a combination of both
hope and necessity like your finances
need to get so bad to the point of like
I have to change but I also believe that
if I do change I can make a difference
you know yeah but also you know that
would not be um necessity wouldn't drive
Graham to do an investment that he's
never done that would be he would change
but the reason he would change is Hope
true only it wouldn't be necessity he
would just be we go that looked pretty
good I've never been over in that space
but everything I've seen about good I
talk to that guy it's good I got that
that pretty good and I get best
practices there and there's some track
record there I can and you know you line
up your basic principles of investing
but you could go to a place you've never
been to that's uncomfortable change uh
based only on the hope it doesn't
require necessity you don't have to go
broke to um learn to stay out of debt
you don't have to go broke to learn to
be on a budget you don't have to go
through drug rehab to figure out drugs
are bad you know you can you know have
to hit bottom to do it but it it's it's
a thorough teacher uh but I don't
recommend it yeah we we just got the
sign we only have 5 minutes left I have
two questions the first question is I
was talking with someone they're well
off financially and I asked them if they
could go back in time would they have
changed anything and they said maybe
just maybe take it a little bit easier
during like their most active years
where their body was at Peak Physical
performance to like go out experience
the World Travel and enjoy those things
while they were young what do you think
about that there there's nothing wrong
with that idea um but again I I feel
like we intentionally made all of those
decisions at the time because it's
always a tradeoff and you just want to
do your trade-offs intentionally okay so
if if we're going to go on a trip and
not work a we're going to be out the
money for the trip B we're going to be
out the money that we didn't work and so
if I'm I had a opportunity the other day
to um do a speaking gig at a a
substantial fee but I had already
promised my wife were going to be in
another country at that time and we've
already booked the trip and I would lose
I would lose that but I could have net
it out and but I I've already decided
what I'm going to do and so it's a
trade-off I made an intentional decision
tradeoff so we've always done that
intentionally so I don't have regrets on
that I don't I don't wish I had done it
another way I mean I wish I hadn't been
as stupid as I've been sometimes but I
guess everybody's done that LE but yeah
but but no in general in general that
it's not a bad idea but I I feel like
I've been intentional enough that feels
like someone that's they just kind of
did stuff on autopilot rather than
thinking about what's the trade-off
what's the trade-off what's the
trade-off and um so like we traveled and
I mean I work my butt off going and
doing Live Events and this kind of stuff
and but we said all right the trade-off
is not fair if we don't Book Live Events
on kids birthdays so I'm at home I did
not miss a kid's birthday I coached
Daniel's ice hockey team when he was a
little guy and I didn't miss those games
I booked booked events around those and
if somebody came up and said well you
can come to no I already made this other
commitment to my son I'm going to do
that so I made it intentional trade-offs
I either gave up business for personal
and and when I didn't I gave up personal
for business but on a a wise way a wise
enough way that the kids didn't lose
their minds because they didn't have a
dad how do you find the balance between
that how do you know how much time to
spend with your family versus how much
time spending with the business number
one that's something Sharon I talk about
a lot so in the old days when I was go
go go go go sometimes she and my
assistant Patty who's been with me 23
years they would come in and go you're
tired uh you're you're you're burning it
we need to dial this back both of them
they they would gang up on me and I go
you know what you're kind of right I had
thought about it I was just getting it I
just out there getting it I was hustling
grinding so people in my life that I
love that that I trust to help me dial
it back and keep it in Balance um and
and it's never in Balance uh uh in the
moment ever it's always in Balance over
time in other words I'm 100% at work
right now so I'm not in Balance yeah you
know but over the scope of this week you
know Sharon and I had dinner last night
out just the two of us so in the scope
of this week I've been a husband in the
scope of this week I'm keeping my
grandson tonight I'll be Papa Dave you
know in the scope of this week I get a
balance or scope of this year I get a
balance if you're training for a
marathon you're not in balance in that
six or eight 10 week period of time
you're you're running in the morning and
you're running hours not just minutes
you know that kind of a thing and I've
done like 15 half marathons so you're
not in balance in the moment but but you
get people in your life and you look for
balance over time over a block of time
and then you don't get caught up in the
well I don't want to work much cuz I'm
such a good
dad bull okay or I work all the time
because it's so important that a good
dad provides that I never see my
children you know that's dumb too okay
so we got to vasolate between these
things you talk to your son every single
Tuesday Daniel we do and I want to know
are there certain things that you share
with him about life about fulfillment
about business practices because you're
trying to train him to take over the
entire company eventually one day at
least that's from what I've imagined
yeah are there certain things that you
share with him that you haven't shared
publicly certain values certain beliefs
that you think will take him far or is
it all just no there's no secrets no
secrets there's no secrets it's just
life and you know we have breakfast
every Tuesday morning and we get those
things in we also get those things in
when we're arguing about something we
also get those things in when we're in
operating board member and there's six
of us working on a project together um
that those things just show up in the
Rhythm of Life uh we might sit and talk
about football at breakfast okay sure
yeah final question to end it off Jack
really short one if you could borrow $1
billion 0% interest for 10 years would
you do it no no easy question no
question even though you could put it in
treasuries and pay off after the 10
years lock in 10e treasury right now 10
or 5% no no it's not worth it no I I
don't borrow money there we go love it
thank you so much for your time I really
appreciate this you just got to remind
everyone to subscribe and hit the like
button hey subscribe hit the like button
it's the iced coffee hour right here it
is thank you guys for watching awesome
enjoyed becoming friends with you too
thanks for hanging out have us back
anytime thank you everyone in the
production room thank you cool beautiful
thank you so much
we could easily go another two hours
doing
this